[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory this
video was actually requested by you guys
in the comment section in the video
we'll be diving into the much wanted
question a haka which teachers paid
surely the highly esteemed Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry pays
its teachers we see the same teachers
year after year with the exception of
the Defense Against the Dark Arts which
changes every year but for many of them
we don't get much of a glimpse into
their personal lives we know that
they're hard-working professionals but
what sort of lifestyles they live the
books and films never really in
lightness as to how they're actually
compensated for their work with the
knowledge of how loyal they are towards
Hogwarts and how vigilantly they work I
would hope that they receive fair
compensation
we know that wizards are a lot more
independent than muggles and are able to
do a lot with magic but they still need
money in the books we aren't given a
whole lot of context or information that
refers to their salaries but we do have
something and that something is a little
tidbit from Slughorn in the half-blood
Prince just before Aragog
burial harry bumps into Slughorn when
Slughorn learns of what harry is up to
he notices an opportunity to collect
some venom in the hopes that he's able
to make a quick galleon or two Slughorn
ends up drunk at Hagrid's and says the
following in reference to the venom that
he's collected seems an awful waste not
to collect it might get a hundred
galleons a pint to be frank my salary is
not large while this isn't much it can
at least help us to begin painting a
picture of what a Hogwarts teacher
salaries like not very large could
potentially give us some insight into
what they make but we also need to
remember that perception of salary size
is completely subjective
we know that Slughorn has a fairly high
standard of living so his idea of a
small salary could be a large salary to
someone like Hagrid who lives in a hut
and incurs very few expenses for the
sake of moving forward with the video we
will take his word for it and approach
this topic from the basis that the
salaries are certainly not outlandish I
think that if he's even consider
collecting venom to earn a quick galleon
then money must be on his mind a more
financially secure person might not even
consider the action that he took if I
had to clump all of the professors
salaries together I'd say it averages
out somewhere in the range of middle
class with junior professors earning a
lower middle class salary regular
professors earning a healthy
middle-class salary and more senior
professors headmasters earning an upper
middle-class salary we know that
Hogwarts is a public school funded by
the Ministry of Magic so it wouldn't
make much sense that they are paid
exorbitant amounts a good way to figure
out their salary could be to compare
them to real-world muggle teachers
according to one British salary website
a newly qualified teacher can expect to
earn somewhere between twenty four
thousand and thirty thousand pounds all
the way at the top of the spectrum is
the head teacher salary who can expect
to earn as much as a hundred and twenty
thousand pounds as the role of head
teacher is sort of in a class of its own
its salary probably is as well so let's
assume that a mid-level teacher earned
approximately thirty to forty five
thousand pounds and a more senior
teacher earns approximately forty-five
to sixty thousand pounds as one galleon
is widely considered to be approximately
five pounds in magical terms these
salaries would be rounded off as follows
junior teacher would be approximately
five to six thousand gallons per year a
mid-level teacher would earn
approximately 6,000 to 9,000 gallons per
year a more senior teacher might expect
to earn nine to twelve thousand gallons
per year and the headmaster should
expect to earn approximately 24,000
gallons per year however given that
Hogwarts teachers of magical I think
that their salaries should be adjusted
to take this into account for this
reason I'm going to somewhat arbitrarily
apply a 20% increase to the above
salaries this leaves us at junior
teacher 6000 to 7200 galleons mid-level
teacher 7,200 to 10,000 800 galleons
senior teacher
10800 galleons - fourteen thousand four
hundred galleons
and headmaster 28,800 galleons a
teacher's level would be
determined by a the duration that
they've been teaching and B the
complexity of the subject bearing all of
that in mind I would expect
approximately the following salaries
from these professors Dumbledore 28,800
galleons Slughorn 13,000 galleons
McGonigle 14,000 galleons Trelawney
8,000 galleons sprout 8,500 galleons
Snape 11,000 gallons and Flitwick 12,000
gallons to name a few one thing that we
should keep in mind is a galleons are
not the only currency in Harry Potter
small forms of currency include Canute's
and sickles Canute's are smallest
followed by sickles and then galleons
the breakdown for their equivalency is
as follows one galleon is equivalent to
17 sickles or 493 Canute's one sickle is
equal to one 17th of a galleon or 29
Canute's and one Knut is equal to one
29th of a sickle or one 490 third of a
galleon to put this into perspective
here are some of the prices of common
objects in the Harry Potter books and
films the entire trolley of candy on the
train was only 11 sickles and seven
Canute's a ride on a night bus is 11
sickles one butterbeer is two sickles an
advanced potion-making textbook is nine
galleons
a wand is seven galleons a cauldron is
15 galleons and a telescope is five
galleons I think that all of this
pricing makes sense in the context of
the professor salaries that I mentioned
above
one other thing that we need to consider
however is that Hogwarts professors have
a lot of benefits as expected with any
government job they're not only paid
salary but are also provided with full
room and board so long as they remain
teaching at the school that sounds like
a good deal to me if you don't have any
dependents and your primary expenses are
fully covered that gives you quite a bit
of disposable income this is probably
how Slughorn is able to live a fairly
cushy lifestyle and
professors like McGonagall are able to
splurge on expensive gifts like the
expensive and sought-after Nimbus 2000
which she got for Harry in a
Philosopher's Stone that is if the
school didn't pay for it and that's it
for this video I could go on and on
about salaries in the Wizarding World
but first I want to hear from you guys
are you interested in what other
Wizarding professions earn what do you
think my estimates for the Hogwarts
professors salaries let me know down in
the comment section below until next
time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]